- There are a lot of people
on the anti-woke side
who don't believe
in free speech.
They don't believe in
debating people's ideas.
They believe in
destroying people.
There are a lot of
people who are unwilling
to have a discussion with
somebody they disagree,
and they spend their
entire time owning people.
Now, look, I go on the BBC
and make them look bad,
and we'll put a clip
out, but I, that's not,
that's not who I am and
it's not what I do, right?
And I think generally,
look, it's hard to be,
and we talked about it earlier,
it's hard to be anti
something and be constructive.
(pensive music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and we
are at the Locals Studio
here in Miami.
And joining me today is
the co-host of the
Trigonometry podcast,
and author of "An Immigrant's
Love Letter to the West",
Konstantin Kisin.
Konstantin, this is bizarre
that we have never
met in person before.
- And it is awesome
that we now have.
- We have.
What should we do now?
- Let's talk.
- (chuckles) Let's
talk about stuff. Okay.
I think some people
sort of think
you are like the British
version of me in a way.
So what's the deal?
- Well, I have a sidekick.
- Can you give me
a little history-
- Listen-
- Of your situation.
- I'll be honest with you, man.
I'm gonna spill the beans.
I used to watch your
show religiously,
particularly 2017-2018.
- Those crazy, formative years.
- Yeah.
And I thought what you
were doing was incredible.
And you showed what was possible
for somebody who is
independent minded,
who wanted to come
in and, you know,
interview interesting people
from a position of perhaps
not knowing very much.
And so I said to
my buddy, Francis,
why don't we do
something like this?
It is genuinely, seeing
you and Joe, you know,
to have these conversations,
was an incredible influence.
And so I'm delighted
to be here with you.
- Well, I'm glad that you are.
Was nobody really doing
that in the UK yet?
The more independent
minded stuff?
Obviously there's a
gajillion chat shows,
and the UK has a long history
of long form interviews
and that kind of thing.
- Yeah. I can't
think off the top.
There are people,
there are other people
who have slightly
different conversations.
But I think that mix of
levity with seriousness,
and that is something that,
it's kind of interesting, 'cause
we're both former standups.
- Yeah.
- And Francis still
does stand up.
And I think that
gives you something,
because you've always got
a way to release tension,
if you need to.
And for us, it's
been very important
because, you know,
we interviewed a
woman, Dr. Ella Hill,
who's a survivor of one
of these grooming gangs.
I don't know if you're
familiar with them?
- Yeah.
- And we interviewed
her for an hour.
And this isn't really
anything to do with us,
but nonetheless,
it's an interview about a victim
of the most heinous crimes,
which is funny.
It's funny. Right?
And that I think
is the magic sauce.
- Was she ready to
be funny about it?
- Yeah, it's all down to her.
We were just able to
play along, that's all.
- Yeah.
So you're, you're out of
the standup game, huh?
- Yeah. I hated the lifestyle.
I enjoyed being on stage,
but driving around for
hours and all of that, nah.
- That's funny,
because for me, too,
I loved, loved,
loved doing standup,
and, you know, I do gigs
still here and there
and book tours and
that kind of thing.
It was never the being on stage
or being at the comedy clubs,
it was everything else.
It was the life that
it could lead to
that I couldn't deal
with, which I think is why
so many comics end up on
drugs or dead, basically.
- It's a, it's, look, there
are harder lives, obviously,
to than-
- No, no, no.
- Standing in front
of people and talking.
- Working in rice fields, maybe.
- You know, getting
home at 2:00 AM,
waking up at, you know, 10:00
the next day is just not,
I can't do it.
And now you and I both are
fathers, so it's not for me.
When lockdown happened
in the UK it forced me
to really reevaluate it.
And my wife, we've been
married for 20 years.
We have the most
beautiful relationship.
But I was working so hard
because we were trying
to get Trigonometry
off the ground,
we were doing
standup, both of us.
Francis was doing-
- Oh, wow.
You married a comic too?
- Well, no, my, I
married a comic?
No, no, I'm talking
about Francis.
Francis, my co-worker.
- I thought you said my wife.
I thought you said my wife,
we did standup, she
did standup too?
- Yeah, sorry. I maybe misspoke.
- Oh.
- Maybe Francis is my
work wife at this point.
No, well, what
was happening was,
basically both Francis and I
were working extremely hard.
And by the time lockdown came,
even though my wife and I
have a beautiful relationship,
it was kind of like
lockdown, sort of,
I wouldn't say it
saved our marriage,
but our son certainly wouldn't
have been born without it.
Do you know what I mean?
Because suddenly I was like,
oh, oh, I'm at home now,
and maybe I should
actually spend some time
with this person
that I claim to love.
- So either I misheard you
or you referred to
him as your wife.
In either case, one of us is
not looking very good here.
- Well, it's probably me.
- (chuckles) Probably
not, probably not.
So for people that just,
that don't know you,
don't know your work, can
you just talk a little bit
about your sort of childhood
and into what got you
into sort of the
cultural political thing
that we're kind
of in the mix of,
and then we'll hit
the issues of the day.
- Well, the short version of is,
I was born in the Soviet
Union in the late eighties
into a family that I was
imbued from a very young age
with stories of my ancestors,
people who starved in the gulags
for saying the wrong thing
or who were really
severely punished.
My grandfather, the way
I ended up in the UK,
is my parents, they were very
wealthy for like three years.
And in that time gap,
they sent me to boarding
school in England
because my
grandfather was there.
And the reason my
grandfather was there,
that it was that in the late
seventies, early eighties,
he criticized the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan.
And he was immediately
ostracized by his friends,
fired from work, his
wife was fired from work,
his children, that's
my father and my aunt,
were kicked out of university,
for him making this
one comment in private.
And so when it came to living
in the UK and doing standup,
and I saw this climate
that was happening,
where suddenly it was very,
very sudden, at least to me,
because I wasn't paying
that much attention,
suddenly words became
this all powerful thing
that was to be treated with
the utmost seriousness,
and jokes could not
be treated as jokes.
If you made a joke that
people didn't like,
they couldn't just say,
"Oh, that's not funny."
Now you had to be punished.
And in addition
to that, you know,
the one thing that I really,
as an immigrant to the UK,
I found very unpleasant was
this idea that all
our social problems,
whether that's, you know,
Brexit or Trump or whatever,
can be explained by claiming
that people are racist.
And that's when I came
across your show actually,
because I was trying
to understand,
because I'd lived in
England for all my,
most of my teenage life
and all of my adult life,
and I'm a dark-skinned
immigrant,
and I experienced racism once
or twice, but it was never,
I never felt like it
was a racist country.
And so when a
referendum like Brexit,
where I voted to
remain, by the way,
equivalently for
Hillary in 2016.
- Interesting.
- And Francis did too
as well, we both did.
When the explanation for that
that was being offered to us
was that half the country
was, I was just like, no,
this is BS, this isn't true.
And that, I think,
is part of the reason
that we really started
to look at these things,
because we felt our
own industry change.
And also we looked around
at society and we just went,
"Something is off.
We're being told
a bunch of lies."
And quite nasty ones as well.
You know, for
Francis particularly,
you know, his father is
an evil straight white man
who married a woman from
Venezuela in the eighties
when that was not the
done thing in England.
And he voted Brexit, and
he was suddenly demonized.
And it just, that
picture of our societies
is so inaccurate that
it was very frustrating.
And I think Trigonometry
was partly born
out of that frustration.
- Right.
It's interesting
because I wasn't talking
about Brexit that much at first,
but then because of the
Trump situation here,
I started having a couple
of people from the UK
and some Americans that
were talking about Brexit.
And then suddenly I had all
these people in the UK watching,
and I was like, well, I didn't
even intend that to happen.
But there was
definitely a connection
between Brexit and the
Trump thing for sure.
- There was, and
the cultural forces
that swirl around those
issues are largely the same.
Now, you guys do
politics very differently
to the way that we do.
But fundamentally,
the way I see it,
it was a sort of, it was
a rebellion of the people.
Whether it was channeled
in the right way
is a different conversation.
But people certainly
in the UK felt
that a lot of their concerns
were not being, not only heard,
but they weren't
even being aired.
And so that I think is
why those two issues
are very similar.
- And did that change
your politics, then,
once you saw the
reaction to Brexit?
I mean, I think, like if I was
to somewhat try to pin you,
I guess I would say you're
a classical liberal.
It has a slightly
different connotation
from a UK perspective.
I have a hard time,
even though I wrote a whole
book defending liberalism,
From an American perspective,
it's almost ridiculous
to call myself a
liberal at this point,
just because people don't
understand the words anymore.
But did that shift your
political ideology?
- I think it maybe
did a little bit,
but mainly I've become
clearer about what I think.
When we started
Trigonometry in early 2018,
I wasn't someone who was
politically educated.
I studied politics
in university,
but it wasn't something where
I had a political philosophy.
You know, I was a
guy who did jokes
about being Russian
onstage for a living.
That's what I did.
So it wasn't something
that I really had
thought about very much.
And that's the
beauty of what we do,
is we get to be
educated by our guests.
That's what I really
enjoy about it.
But in terms of where I am now,
it's hard to place
because a lot of,
it's a sad thing to say,
but a lot of what I do
is being in
opposition to things.
And it's actually something
I've been thinking
and talking about a lot
of getting past that,
because we're gonna have to.
But up until this
point, you know,
I say that I reject wokeness
because I'm a liberal.
- [Dave] Right.
- That is my position.
- It's the most
illiberal ideology
permeating throughout
the West right now.
- Right, and I reject
it also because
I don't believe
in discrimination.
And if you believe in actual
equality of opportunity
and that people should
be treated equally
irrespective of who they are,
you cannot possibly be woke.
It's not possible, right?
It's also not possible,
of course, to, you know,
to go in the other direction.
But that's about where I am.
And in terms of, you
know, a more where I am
in terms of what I see
from a positive side,
it's much, it gets much harder
because I don't really,
I'm not ideological.
I sort of pick positions
based on whether
that particular thing makes
sense to me, you know?
And so on certain things
people would place me
probably on the, like,
because now believing in a
border makes you right wing,
now I'm on the right, I
suppose on that issue.
On others I'm very liberal,
socially in particular.
- Right.
So, which is odd to me
also, not odd to me,
but it's interesting to
me to see this realignment
because here I am in Florida,
I'm married to a
man, I'm a father,
I'm fully wholly embraced
by everything going on here
in this sort of new freedom
conservative movement.
And if you were to
listen to the media,
this is the most
homophobic, racist, bigoted,
backwards place in the world.
And from where I sit,
it's literally the freest,
as DeSantis says, "the
citadel of freedom" right now.
- Hmm.
Well, I've only
been here for a day,
so I haven't had much
of a chance to find out.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, look-
- But they haven't
come to get you yet?
- They haven't.
- Yes.
And what's interesting
to me is that
we are sort of in
a position now,
because we've been
lied to so much
and because words have been
debased to such an extent,
they could say that, you
know, DeSantis is whatever,
I wouldn't be likely
to believe it.
And I actually think
that's such a big-
- And that's a
damn shame, right?
- It's not just a shame, it's
very dangerous in my opinion,
because if you look, look,
I was not a fan of Donald Trump.
I remain not a fan
of Donald Trump.
But as someone whose
Jewish ancestors
fought on the Eastern Front
to defeat Nazi Germany,
it is an insult to them and
to me to imply that this guy,
whatever your view
of his politics,
whose daughter married
the Jewish man,
who he then appointed
to serve him,
he is a Nazi.
- Yeah.
- He hates Jews.
He's anti-Semitic.
It's an insult.
And it's dangerous because
the problem we have is,
some people are Nazis, and
we have to be able to say,
that's a Nazi,
that's not a Nazi,
and for that to be believed.
And so this erosion
of language is,
people don't understand
how dangerous it is.
I think it is genuinely
a major issue.
- You know, one of the
things that I said,
I think the day after
Trump was elected,
and I didn't vote for
him the first time,
I did the second time.
I said, you know, guys,
let's pause for a second here
because let's see what happens.
But once you keep
calling him Hitler
and all his supporters Nazis,
it's not what you're
doing to them,
it's what you're
doing to yourself,
because you're painting
yourself in a corner.
Now if the economy's doing well
and we're not going to war,
I mean, a bunch of things
that were happening under him,
you can't suddenly be like,
"Ah, you know, that Hitler,
pretty good, pretty,
you know, pretty good."
Right?
- Yeah.
- And so that's I think has
led to a lot of the hysteria.
- It has.
And you know, I
think while you and I
wouldn't be sitting here
without social media,
social media's had a big impact
on the way we communicate.
And not in a good way.
- Yeah.
- Because-
- Do you see it as a
net negative, actually?
I always struggle with that.
It's like, wow, look at my life.
Look what I've been able to do
and all the people I've
been able to connect with
and the new ideas
that we can all share,
or even old ideas that
we can finally share
in a sensible way.
- Right.
- And yet the anxiety, the
craziness, the doomscrolling.
- Hmm.
Obviously you and I
being able to sit here
and have this conversation is
worth society being screwed
(Dave laughs)
for the next few decades.
I think we're in a,
we are, you know,
we are living through the
next information revolution.
You know, the invention
of the printing press.
You get two centuries
of religious war
and all that craziness.
That's what we are
going through now.
Can you stop this?
I mean, there was a guy
who tried called Ted,
it didn't-
- Yeah.
- You know, that,
what are you gonna do?
So I think what we have to do is
make the best of what we've got.
But that starts
with acknowledging
the sort of problems that
social media has caused,
because we now live
in a world where
making sure that what
you say sounds good
is much more important
than being a good person.
And that's a problem.
- Yeah.
- That's a problem.
- Because you know from,
I don't know if this
is the same here,
but on the British
comedy circuit,
anyone who was
really nice on stage
was probably groping a
woman in the green room.
- Oh yeah.
- Right?
- It's always the biggest
feminists on stage
that are doing all
that stuff, yeah.
- Exactly. And vice versa.
The people whose
material was grotesque
and offensive and whatever,
they're usually the people
that actually were really
decent behind the scenes.
- Yeah.
- And the other
thing is, you know,
sometimes I think people wonder
why our institutions
have been so captured.
And I think a big
part of the reason is
progressive ideas sound good.
All things to all
men, I mean, you know,
equality for everybody,
and, you know,
I grew up in the Soviet
Union and we saw all that,
but we didn't have social media.
And now the problem with a lot
of the classically liberal
and conservative ideas
is they don't sound good.
"What, I have to take
responsibility for my life?
What, I have agency?
What, some things are my fault?"
Who wants to hear that?
- Right. Right.
Well, they do sound good
once you're a little older,
but I suppose when you're
15 they don't sound good.
And now people are
perpetually 15.
- I think that's
exactly what's going on.
And so yeah, we're all
gonna, as a society,
have to come up with some
answers to what we do about it.
- Do you see any
of it as a fault
or a flaw within classical
liberalism itself?
I mean, when I've
watched so many,
and I want to talk about
a moment on your podcast
that really went
viral with Sam Harris.
But when I've seen so many of
sort of the old school libs
just kind of collapse under
this thing and become,
either go woke or become
largely irrelevant
because they can't make
sense of the new world.
Do you think that there's like
an actually inherent problem
with classical liberalism?
- Well, I think the people
you're talking about
the sort, what you'd call libs,
or what in the UK we
would call center left.
- Right, right, right, right.
So that's why the, the
words can be a little-
- Yeah.
- Confusing.
- But I think people
will know what we mean.
- Yeah.
- I think their problem
is they don't wanna be me
and they don't wanna be you.
That's their problem.
And they're cowards.
They are terrified.
They're terrified of the
extremists on their own team.
And so they won't speak up.
And when they do, what happens?
They get called right wing
and all the rest of it.
So a lot of them, you know,
we saw your journey and
we were inspired by that.
A lot of people see your
journey or our journey,
and they're very
put off by that.
They don't wanna be called names
that they're uncomfortable with.
So I think it's that.
- Did you have a moment
where you decided
to walk through the fire?
Because I think about, people
always ask me about that.
And I don't know that I,
I know I had my wake up moments,
you know, my moment with
Larry Elder and this or that.
But I don't know that I
had like an actual moment,
like sitting down with
myself being like,
let's just go through.
I just, I just
kept going, really.
- Yeah.
You know, it was never
that hard for me,
if I'm being honest.
You know, when you've
got grandparents
who spent 15 years in the gulag
for saying the wrong thing,
when you come from a
country in which people
were beaten to death
and tortured to death
and executed for
speaking their mind,
it's not, you know, people say,
people say, "Oh,
you're so brave."
Come on.
That's silly.
So I was never really
that scared of the,
and plus I'm a
contrarian arsehole,
(Dave laughs)
so I like pissing people off.
I like saying the thing that
people don't want to hear even,
that is true, and
that needs to be said.
So, I embrace, I'm quite a
combative person by nature.
I try to temper that, but I
quite like it, to be honest.
I wouldn't have
it any other way.
- Yeah. It's interesting.
I think one of the things that
kept me sane throughout this
was I didn't do
this for friends.
And I think a lot of people
do a lot of this for friends
and to be liked, and
it's nice to be liked,
I'm not saying it isn't.
But my best two friends,
one of them I met the first
day at kindergarten, 1981,
and one of them I met the
first day of 3rd grade,
you know, a couple
years after that.
So as I saw people
kind of like me
and then they suddenly
didn't like me,
I was just kind of
like, all right, well.
- And it's still painful. I
remember you going through that.
I remember you would talk
a lot about, you know,
this friend and that friend,
and I understand that.
- Yeah.
- For me it was easier
because, if I'm being honest,
I never liked 99% of the
people I was working with.
- It must be nice being
a total contrarian.
I would say I'm
like a begrudging
contrarian or something.
- Right, no I-
- But there must be
something very refreshing
about the full thing.
- I like the space I'm in now.
I really get on with
people in this space
because we operate
in the same way.
But comedians tend to process
the world through emotions.
And I don't.
And I get very tired of
people who believe things
because those things
make them feel good,
as opposed to
because they're true.
So, you know, when
I was doing standup,
I would leave a gig the moment
I was done 90% of the time.
- You didn't wanna sit down
with all the alcoholics
and complain about all
the problems in the world
and not have a
dollar between ya?
- No, no.
And you know, I'm, even
though I'm an adopted Brit,
I have a much more American
attitude about life.
I want to be successful.
I want to be great.
I want to be the
best at what I do.
I don't mean, you know,
have the most
subscribers or whatever,
I just, I want to get better.
I wanna improve.
I wanna create.
I wanna build a team,
I wanna build a business.
I wanna build a YouTube channel.
And that's not an attitude
you're allowed to have
in the British sort of
creative arts, you know?
It's funny, I
remember I met a guy
who I haven't seen
for a long time,
and he had just opened on
tour for Ricky Gervais,
which is a huge achievement.
Huge achievement.
- That's pretty good.
Pretty good.
- And I was like, "Oh
man, congratulations."
He was like, "Oh yeah,
I got really lucky."
I was like,
"What do you mean?
I've seen your
work for 10 years."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But we do have that
sort of, you know,
you gotta play yourself
down a little bit in the UK.
And I can't do that.
- So let's talk about
one of the guys.
And you said to me right
before, you know my rules,
I have no rules on this show.
And you said to me
right before we started
that you have no
rules, in essence,
but you don't like to talk
bad about former guests.
And I try not to
do that as well.
But I wanna show a-
- That will be
tested all the time.
- It will be, right.
No, right, well, I
hate to tell you,
it's gonna really be tested
the longer you do this,
but yeah.
In any event, we played
a clip, we played two,
I think two clips from
you over the last year.
I want to show
people both of them.
The first one I wanna throw to
is you guys had Sam
Harris on the podcast.
This is what, about
six months ago now?
Roughly?
- It was closer to a year ago.
- Oh, wow.
- It was last sort of August,
July, August, I think.
- Wow, times flies.
- Yeah, it does, yeah.
- All right, so it's about
eight months or so ago,
whatever it is.
- Our last trip to the US.
- And do you wanna
set it up in any way
or should we just throw to
it and then we'll dissect it.
- No, you go for it.
- All right.
So let's throw it to the clip.
- I mean, Hunter
Biden, at that point,
Hunter Biden literally
could have had
the corpses of children
in his basement.
I would not have cared. Right?
It's like, there's nothing,
first of all, it's
Hunter Biden, right?
It's not, it's like,
it's not Joe Biden,
but even if Joe
Biden, like even,
whatever scope of Joe Biden's
corruption is, like if you,
if we could just go down
that rabbit hole endlessly
and understand that
he's getting kickbacks
from Hunter Biden's
deals in Ukraine
or wherever else,
right, or China,
it is infinitesimal
compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved in.
It's like a firefly
to the sun, right?
I mean, like, there's
just, it doesn't even,
it doesn't even stack up
against Trump University, right?
Trump University
as a story is worse
than anything that could be
in Hunter Biden's laptop,
in my view, right?
Now that's not, that doesn't
answer the people who say
it's still completely
unfair to not have
looked at the laptop
in a timely way
and to have shut
down the, you know,
the New York Post's
Twitter account.
Like that's a,
just a conspiracy,
that's a left wing conspiracy
to deny the presidency
to Donald Trump.
Absolutely it was.
Absolutely, right?
But I think it was
warranted, right?
And again, it's a coin
toss as to whether or not-
- Sam, I'm sorry-
- That particular piece is-
Yeah?
- I'm really sorry.
I was the one that
said we should move on,
but you've just said something
I really struggle with it.
- Go for it.
- Which is...
- The kid, the kids,
the kids in the basement?
- You, no, no.
Fuck the kids in the basement.
I'm interested in democracy.
You are saying you are content
with a left wing conspiracy
to prevent somebody
being democratically
reelected as president.
- Well, no, I'm content.
Well, so it's, but the thing
is, it's just not left wing.
Right? So Liz Cheney
is not left wing.
Liz Cheney is doing-
- You're content
with a conspiracy-
- Everything in her power-
- To prevent somebody being
democratically elected?
- It's not a, no, but
there's nothing, conspiracy.
It's not, it was a
conspiracy out in the open.
It doesn't, but it doesn't
matter if it was a,
it doesn't matter what
part's conspiracy,
what part's out in the open.
I mean, I think it's like,
if people get together
and talk about what should
we do about this phenomenon,
you know, if it's
like, if there,
if there was an asteroid
hurdling toward Earth.
And we got in a room together
with all of our friends
and had a conversation
about what we could do
to deflect its course, right?
Is that a conspiracy?
- Man, that is something,
because I know that Sam
obviously was influential
in your political and I
guess cultural evolution.
And you sort of tried to
save him there, but...
- Well, I like Sam, a
lot, and I would say
that out of all the guests that
we've ever had on the show,
he's probably been, present
company excepted, the-
- (chuckles) I am the...
- The nicest person that
we've had, in terms of,
we actually on that day
had massive tech issues,
and he sat there for 40
minutes waiting for us
to get the camera rolling.
He was incredible,
and he made us feel really
comfortable about that.
So on a personal level,
I really like Sam.
And that's why, you
know, I would sort of go,
Sam, there's a cliff there.
Please don't walk off it.
And you know, his comments
speak for themselves.
I thought that,
I disagree with what
he said, fundamentally.
And I think you could see
that on both our faces.
- Right, right.
But you were trying
to sort of save him,
but the only reason
I'm really showing it
is not to bash him,
it truly isn't.
But it seemed like it
almost, in some ways,
a final nail in the coffin
on this odd adventure
that he's been on intellectually
over the last couple years,
going all in on the Trump hate
that you described earlier,
related to other people.
Or thanking Jack Dorsey for
banning Donald Trump on Twitter,
when the whole idea of
what we were all doing
was in free speech.
So that's why I think the moment
caught fire the way that it did.
- Yeah.
I think the reason that that
clip went super viral was that
Sam showed people the thing
that they always suspected
was there, motivating the thing.
And it's a hard one,
because I, you know,
the first thing I did
actually after it happened
is email Sam and just
make sure he was okay,
because it's not easy.
- You mean after
it had gone viral?
- After it had gone viral.
Just to make sure that,
you know, he was okay,
because I wouldn't want a
guest to come on the show
and then, you know, who knows
what happens from there.
I was kind of
concerned, to be honest.
But he was very generous.
And actually he said he
thought we did a great job.
Yeah.
I think with that,
my fundamental disagreement
with Sam about this is that
it's a threat misassessment
in my opinion.
And if you exaggerate
the threat in your head,
you are then willing
to take actions
that you otherwise would not,
and violate principles that
you otherwise would not.
And we saw this as,
you know, during COVID.
People get scared.
People overestimate the
nature of the threat,
and then the reaction they
demand from their government
or they themselves have is
just completely out of whack.
And so destroying democracy
to prevent Donald Trump,
that doesn't make sense
to me, personally.
- Right.
So let's talk about the
COVID thing a little bit,
because obviously it has
framed almost everything
over the last couple of years.
I went radically
anti-mandate and pro-freedom.
Literally moved my entire
life across the country
in the midst of it because
of all of the craziness.
I sense you're in a similar
spot when it came to mandates
and things of that matter.
But what was your evolution
like, related to all that?
- I supported the first
lockdown in the UK.
We didn't know
what was going on.
And we were told it
was very dangerous.
And while we should all
be skeptical, of course,
of what the mainstream
media tell us
in that sort of situation.
I do think, as a
responsible citizen,
you do have a duty to
at least consider it.
And remember, what we
were told in the UK
it's just gonna be three weeks.
We're gonna solve the problem.
Everything's fine.
- [Dave] Oh, they
told you three week?
- Three weeks.
- We got two weeks.
- Two weeks, right.
- They told us either
two weeks or 15 days,
they were always working
with one extra day.
- The longest three
weeks in human history,
those turned out to be.
So in the beginning I
supported the first lockdown,
you know, but from there,
I just felt that we went
in a dystopian direction
very, very quickly.
And on the basis of data that
to me didn't seem reasonable,
we were forced to wear
these face nappies
that don't do
anything as we know.
And not only do we know that
now, we knew that before.
We knew that before. Right?
And I think it signals to me
something I talk about
in the book, actually,
that we are importing
ways of doing business
that are fundamentally
anti-western.
And we have this from the UK.
Neil Ferguson, not the
historian who we love.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- But the guy who
was essentially
behind advising the government
to have the lockdowns,
he was a scientist in the UK.
- Oh, that must have been
tough for our Niall Ferguson.
- Yeah, I imagine so.
- Oh man!
- So he said in, I think
it's a Times article,
that we didn't know
lockdowns were possible
until we saw what the
Chinese were doing.
- I mean, what a horrific...
- And I think this speaks
to something else, you know,
one of the things I
mentioned in the book is
most people don't,
do you know where political
correctness comes from?
The term itself?
- The term political
correctness?
- [Konstantin] Yeah.
- I don't think so.
- The Soviet Union.
And it never had anything to do
with protecting the
rights of minorities
and not offending
people or being nice
or anything like that.
It was a very simple thing,
to tell people,
like my ancestors,
"Comrade, this may
be factually correct,
but it is politically
incorrect."
And what that means is,
you are not adhering to
the party line, right?
And to me, the fact
that we adopted
a Chinese style response
to that sort of threat
signals that we are moving in
an authoritarian direction.
And the thing that scared
me most, this is, look,
this is not a popular thing
to say, but I think it's true,
at least in our country.
It wasn't the politicians
that did this.
It was the people.
They wanted this.
Poll after poll, after
poll, after poll.
You know, 20% of people
want nightclubs shut down
permanently,
irrespective of COVID,
irrespective of COVID, Dave.
They wanna shut down things,
just because there's an
opportunity to do so.
Wear masks on public
transport, 40% or 30%, forever,
doesn't matter if there's COVID.
You know, we shat the bed.
And I'm really uncomfortable
with what happened.
- You know what
day it was for me
that I realized what nonsense
it was, 'cause I'm with you.
The first two weeks I granted
everybody a long leash.
And I can even
grant, in retrospect,
I can even grant a longer leash.
We were so hit in the head.
It was the first time
we had dealt with this.
I think we've all learned a lot
and hopefully a certain portion
of us won't do it again.
But for me it really was day 15.
Once they said two weeks
to stop the spread,
and we rolled into day 15,
'cause it changed overnight.
They kept saying the new normal.
And once I started hearing
the new normal everywhere,
it was on commercials,
it was on NBC, CNN,
I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Something else is going on here.
And then that clearly
bore out to be true.
But what do you think that
says about human nature
or the spiritual side
of what's going on here?
That we actually wanted it.
And from an American
perspective,
I don't know if this is quite
true from a UK perspective,
we've re-voted,
we voted in a lot of the
same people that did this.
Gretchen Whitmer, Gavin Newsom,
the list goes on and on.
- Well, we know this
throughout history.
I sort of joked during the
pandemic at some point that,
you know, this is at
least the one thing
that hasn't happened yet,
is that we haven't
blamed the Jews.
But we did just
about everything,
It was just about
everything else, right?
So when people are
scared, when people,
when bad things are going
on, people, you know, they,
the instincts come out and
their worst side comes out.
And it's like human
beings, you know,
only on an individual level,
when you're having a bad day,
all your worst aspects of
your personality are magnified
and the best ones
are dampened, right?
And I tell you
what it was for me.
For me it was what
happened over BLM in the UK
that really showed me that
this is a complete nonsense.
Because we had this
first lockdown, which I,
and almost everybody
obeyed to the letter,
and had a lot of respect for.
There was another moment
when the sun first came out,
it's a rare
occurrence in England.
And some people had the temerity
to go outside and sunbathe.
- My God.
- And this was, by this
point it was very clear
that this virus does not
spread well outdoors.
And I said on Twitter
that, you know,
I think people should be
allowed to sunbathe and I,
it was, I,
I don't know what I
could compare it to,
the reaction that I got.
So I thought people were
starting to lose their minds.
But then we saw
the whole country
having been locked down
for this entire time.
BLM happens.
And suddenly protests
outside without masks
are a public health
intervention?
- They were actually
pro-public health.
That's what we were told here-
- They had to be-
- Because racism was
a bigger problem.
- They're to be celebrated.
- Yeah.
- They're to be encouraged.
If you want to live in a
western liberal democracy
in which people are
judged on the content
of their character,
that can't happen.
That can't happen.
And to me, that was the
moment when I just went,
okay, this is done.
And to the point where,
you know, we were,
I remember going to
speaking at a protest
in Parliament Square,
outside the Houses of
Parliament in London,
when they were trying
to force medical staff
to have a vaccine in order
to remain in their post.
And it's interesting, I've
never told this story publicly,
or maybe, no, I
don't think I have.
When my wife gave birth,
she had quite a long
and difficult labor.
And it was supposed
to be at home.
She wanted to give
birth at home.
But we had to go to to hospital
'cause it wasn't going well.
And it was a long and
difficult and scary
and all the rest of it.
But as it was looking
like, you know,
things were gonna get really
bad, this midwife came in
who was a higher level
midwife than the other ones.
And she was like this
angel, she was incredible.
And she helped my wife
to give birth naturally.
It was just like,
she fixed the thing.
It was beautiful.
It was amazing.
And afterwards, all the
other midwives had left
and she was just
filling out some forms
and she was asking
us various questions.
And my wife who was
pregnant at the time,
the vaccine came out,
wasn't gonna have it.
And this midwife was
reading the thing.
She goes, oh, this,
asking various questions.
Then she said, "Are
you vaccinated?"
And I, you know, I, my
wife's just given birth,
I'm sort of trying
to look after her.
I don't want it to,
you know, but equally,
I don't want, you know,
this medical professional
to think that we are
the wackos and whatever.
- [Dave] Yeah yeah yeah.
- So I said, "Well, you
know, we were pregnant",
and I start sort of
fumbling for an answer
that will please both
sides, which is unlike me.
And she said, "Oh, don't
worry, I'm not vaccinated."
And we had a conversation.
I said, "So you must
have, you must have not,
you must have felt really
bad when the government
was trying to force
you to be vaccinated?"
And she said, "I
was gonna quit."
That woman would
not have been there
if the government had
carried on with that program.
And so for all the crap we took
for standing up on that issue,
I felt that to me was
the ultimate vindication,
that that happened.
It's a story that
I really appreciate
and think about a lot, you know,
and that's when, you know,
we talked about being
brave and whatever, just,
it's nonsense.
We just gotta, we all
gotta say what we believe.
- So since the woke
thing is kind of what,
what I think has really
put you on the map,
do you see the
precursor to COVID,
with all of the woke craziness
that we were dealing
with before COVID,
then COVID comes,
now everyone's brains
are completely broken.
Does it seem like sort
of fairly obvious to you
that we're at where
we're at right now?
That if you had three
years or whatever we had
of like hardcore
wokeness online,
then we get three
years of COVID,
and now we're just in
this like post COVID,
woke broken weirdness.
- Yeah, I think COVID broke
a lot of people's brains,
left and right.
Because you and I both know,
social media's not good for you.
And we all spent three years
just downloading
Twitter into our heads.
A lot of people did.
So I think that's
had a huge impact.
But I think the
bigger question is,
we don't have a shared
consensus anymore.
We don't.
And how can you, how can
you have a, you know,
you talk about classical
liberalism, that means,
part of that means the ability
to discuss ideas
and debate ideas.
How can you debate ideas if
you don't agree on reality?
Right? There is no
basis in reality.
And I actually, it's
interesting because,
I don't know if you
saw Gavin Newsom's
non-campaign campaign
ads recently?
- Oh, I saw them.
- You saw that.
- We played them.
I don't know if you know this,
I don't like that guy-
- Yeah, I imagine so.
But what I found interesting
about that is, he was using
all the, quote unquote,
tropes of people on the right.
And so he's basically saying,
"I believe in freedom."
- No, it's incredible,
that he has the gall to put
any of this in his mouth,
it's incredible, and everyone's
the reverse of the truth.
We went through the list.
- Right.
But there are people
who believe that.
And there are people
on the other side
who believe the opposite.
And so that lack
of shared consensus
is really where
the problem's at.
- So you got a solution on that?
What do you, I mean, I talk
about this all the time,
what do we do about that?
I mean, I know, I think it
was a very tactical move
that Gavin did that,
to use the words freedom to
talk about all of the things
that are happening in Florida
as if they're negative
relative to freedom.
- Yeah.
- And that we're the ones
banning books. Not true.
It's actually him trying to
find "To Kill a Mockingbird"
in California state schools.
All of these things, you know,
women's rights
and your own body.
It's like, "Wait,
you were the one
trying to inject everybody
with your stuff."
You know, all the nonsense.
But what do we do with that,
as that continues to break down?
- Well...
I oscillate between two
different thoughts on this.
I've talked a lot about the
post-woke future because to me,
a lot of the people who I would
hope were on our side once,
I see them as equally
abominable now, as the woke.
The anti-woke is becoming
a parody of itself.
- What would be an
example of that?
- There are many
examples of that.
I mean, there are a lot of
people on the anti-woke side
who don't believe
in free speech.
They don't believe in
debating people's ideas.
They believe in
destroying people.
There are a lot of
people who are unwilling
to have a discussion with
somebody they disagree,
and they spend their
entire time owning people.
Now look, I go on the BBC
and make them look bad
and we'll put a clip out.
But I, that's not,
that's not who I am and
it's not what I do, right?
- Yeah.
- And I think generally,
look, it's hard to be anti,
we talked about earlier,
it's hard to be anti
something and be constructive.
It's hard, objectively.
- Yeah.
- And so for me, the answer,
when I talk about going
for a post-woke future,
culturally at least,
what that means to me is
I don't believe that,
before we started, we
talked about the NBA.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Which was very
heavily politicized.
I don't think the
average person,
the average person,
wants to turn on the NBA
and watch a bunch of
players talking about BLM.
I also, by the way,
don't think you want
to turn on the NBA
and watch a bunch
of players talking
about how CRT is destroying
schools and all of that.
I have this strange feeling
they wanna watch
some basketball.
- Dribble the damn
ball. How about that?
- Well, you know,
that is a loaded phrase now
because of who uttered it.
But for me, you know,
I think people want
to enjoy the content.
I think that is
also true of drama,
of comedy, of all
of these things.
So as people crave
that more and more,
I think that's where
we're gonna end up.
And I think it
behooves comedians
and people who are in
the creative space,
to try and, perhaps,
you attack both sides
and therefore bring
them together,
or bring them together just
by bringing them together,
by focusing on the things
that are common to all people.
And on the story,
drama for example,
doesn't have to be
anti-woke or woke,
it just has to be good.
And the problem, certainly,
I dunno about this country,
but in the UK, with comedy,
it just got ruined by,
you know, Mock the Week,
which was a huge show,
The Mash Report,
that I used to
write on actually.
They both got destroyed by being
excessively political
in one direction,
and also by an artificial
focus on people's faces
instead of how good
they were at writing
or performing or whatever.
So I think part of the answer
just lies into not going back,
but going forward to a place
where not everything has
to be about politics.
And I think that's part of it.
However, you know, I was on
Michael Malice's show recently,
and he, you know, I was
talking about how I'm concerned
about what's happening
in this country,
just as an outsider
observing it,
about the heatedness
of everything.
And he said, "Well
look, you're right.
But I don't think there's
a pressure valve release
that's gonna happen because,
you know, if Trump runs,
the heat is gonna
be higher, and what,
they're gonna stop
calling him fascist?"
So it's difficult.
I think culturally
what we gotta do
is play to the
80% in the middle,
who don't care about either.
- Right.
Malice has sat in
that very chair
and said something very similar.
It's funny, because
he oscillates,
I think, between
that black pill,
and the book, obviously,
was "The White Pill".
- Yeah.
- It seems to me we
just have to figure out
how to build new things
and separate from them.
But I agree with Malice,
they're never gonna stop.
The question is, can
we build fast enough
to have lasting things
before they take everything
that was good from
you and good from us?
- Yeah.
And the one thing I'm really
trying to think about a lot,
and I think be becoming a father
really helped me with this,
to become a little bit
more empathetic to people.
We were young and
stupid once as well.
And these woke kids, they
don't know any better.
I think we have to remember
that they're open to persuasion.
You know, I don't know if you
saw my Oxford Union speech?
- That's the other clip
that I want to go to.
- That's the other clip, right.
So I really tried to
speak to people in a way
so that they could hear.
And I think that's also part
of what we've gotta be doing.
I think we have to be less
partisan ourselves. We all do.
We all do.
And I think there are things
that I agree with
left-wing people on,
and there are things that I
agree with right-wing people on.
And I try to just find that
middle and speak to them.
And one of the things
that therefore happens is,
I kind of
deliberately, actually,
piss off elements of our
audience, we both do,
on purpose, to sort of,
to prune the extremists.
And I think that's the way
you culturally do that.
Whether our politics can
survive the social media age,
that's a very
different conversation.
- Right.
It's interesting, because
when I was going through
my political awakening and
the show was taking off,
and then I suddenly had all
these lefties who once loved me
now telling me I was a
sellout and all this stuff,
it was like, you
mean I'm selling out
to just get endless hate and
like traverse this new area
that I don't know what
the hell's gonna happen?
Now there's this whole obviously
sort of anti-woke thing,
but I was just like
walking into the dark.
Like, I don't know if any
of this is gonna work,
I'm just doing what I think.
But usually people's,
people have a way of going
after your motives, let's say.
- You know, what's
interesting is,
the more you become a
public figure to any extent,
the more you realize
how ridiculous
what you think about
other people is.
Like, "I know what
Dave Rubin thinks."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, I know you get a
lot of shit, because, you know,
you kind of, you
were, you started out,
I'm on the left, and
now you, you know,
you picked a team, to
some extent, right,
in terms of politically
at least, right?
- I think you gotta pick a
team to make things happen.
Absolutely. Yeah.
- And you're perfectly
entitled to the view.
But what's more,
I don't understand why
people can't understand
that people change their mind
over time and over experience.
I imagine it is not uncommon
for someone who starts out
and builds a very
successful business
to become more right-wing
on the economy.
I mean, the more tax you
pay, the more it hurts.
- You know, 100%.
I used to say this all the time,
that my life was an
example of the ideas
that I was talking
about on the show.
'Cause I agree with you.
I wasn't an expert in
a lot of these things,
but I was talking to Jordan,
and I was talking to
Sam and all these guys.
And then my career
started taking off,
the business
started being built.
I was dealing with
taxes and employees
and all of these things,
and I have more of this sort
of freedom set of ideas.
And I was like, oh, I'm putting
these things into place,
but I'm trying to build a
studio in a garage in LA
where they have
8,000 regulations,
and I can't put a
vent over there.
And now it's too loud.
And like, so all of the things
that I was talking about,
I actually was living through.
And I think that that
solidified a lot of it.
- And that's why I, you know,
I never have any
respect for people
who make that argument
about you or about others.
People are gonna change
their mind over time.
They're gonna develop
their own positions.
And if someone started
out being liberal
and then became a conservative,
well, people do that.
- Right.
- It's quite a normal thing.
I mean, people have done
this for millennia, so-
- Although it's a little curious
when people go the other way
as they get older, right?
- Yeah.
- There aren't many
examples of that, actually.
- I mean, that one is
harder to understand.
I agree with you. Yeah.
It's harder to understand.
- Yeah.
So let's throw, actually,
to the Oxford University
speech that you mentioned,
'cause this thing, how many
views did this thing get?
- It's hard to to say.
Probably somewhere between
100 and 200 million views,
across different
platforms, yeah.
- Ooh, lordy lordy.
All right, let's go.
- And the only thing
that wokeness has
to offer in exchange
is to brainwash bright,
young minds like you
to believe that you are victims,
to believe that
you have no agency,
to believe that what you must do
to improve the world
is to complain,
is to protest,
is to throw soup on paintings.
(people chuckle)
(people clap)
And we on this side of the house
are not on this
side of the house
because we do not wish
to improve the world.
We sit on this side of
the house because we know
that the way to improve
the world is to work,
is to create, it is to build.
And the problem
with woke culture
is that it's trained too
many young minds like yours
to forget about that.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(people cheer)
- The brainwashing element is
pretty interesting of this,
that that's hard to
get people out of.
They feel like they have this
kind of holistic worldview
and that somehow
everyone before them
was an idiot or a moron.
That's the one I can't get over.
- Yeah.
To be honest, I
think young people
always think that about
other generations.
That, you know, that
thing about when I was 20,
my dad was an idiot.
- Yeah.
- And by the time I got 40,
he had really wisened up.
Like, I think we all
experienced that at some level.
So my issue is that,
you know, look,
culture is the brainwashing
of young people.
That's what culture is.
It's a passing down of
certain values and beliefs
about what it is to be human
and how we ought to
conduct ourselves, right?
That's why you have
an education system.
cultural content.
That's why we teach
children certain values.
We are, quote unquote,
brainwashing them.
My issue is that, I've never
understood this, you know,
as a first generation
immigrant, I sort of,
people want to tell
me that I'm a victim,
and I've never understood.
And it doesn't really
matter if it's true or not.
What matters is, is it useful?
And that's my issue
with all of this stuff.
It's like why are
you teaching children
things that will make them fail?
Why are you teaching children
things that will make them hurt,
things that will
make them anxious,
make them depressed?
Why are you not teaching them,
look, you believe in
climate change, go for it.
Go and fix a problem
to do with that issue.
Go and learn and study
for years and work hard.
And you know what, Melissa
Chen, I don't know, you-
- Oh, I know her well,
she's a good friend.
- A wonderful person.
I love Melissa.
I think it was her
that tweeted out
something a long time ago.
She said, "You can't remain
woke if you build something.
Whether that's muscle, a
business, or anything."
And that's why I would
challenge those young people,
very bright, young
people at Oxford.
They are the future.
Whether you like it or not,
they are gonna be the people
running our countries, right?
I challenge them to recognize
that if you care about
whatever issue it
is, you gotta fix it.
You can't just sit and mope.
- Were you shocked how
many students at Oxford
are buying that stuff?
'Cause when I spoke there,
it was a lovely talk,
and I did my thing and
then there was some Q&A
and I was getting some
pushback on stuff.
But I didn't feel it had fully
sort of proliferated throughout.
But I get the sense
that it's deeper now.
That was probably five years ago
when I was on tour with Jordan.
- Yeah, it's hard to say,
'cause you see, you know,
400 people or 500 people
who came to see the debate.
So what the mix of it
is, it's hard to say.
You know, the thing that really
I found very reassuring is
I had a few people, the
people won't know this,
but the debate started
like three hours later
than it should have done.
So we ended up sitting
in the pub waiting.
And there was this girl
that came up to me,
and she could not
believe, she said,
"So you think there are
are woke people in the UK?"
And I went, "Yeah."
And she went, "So
you think there are
woke people in the media?"
"Yeah."
And she was like, "So
give me an example?"
And I'd give her an example.
And we went round and
round for an hour.
Anyway, after the debate, she-
- You go, lady, I
got a big talk to do.
- After the debate,
she comes over to me
and asks for a selfie.
So, you know, we gotta be,
we gotta be willing to try
to change people's minds.
And I have hope
for young people,
because I was young and stupid,
and probably am still to some
extent both of those things.
And, you know, people
are persuadable.
And you persuaded me,
your guests persuaded me,
and I believe that we
can persuade others.
- What about the people
that are pushing it sort of,
I don't wanna say blindly,
but did you see a clip
about month and a half ago,
on Real Time with Bill Maher,
where he asked Bernie Sanders
if he knew the difference
between equity and equality?
Did you happen to see the clip?
- I didn't see that one, no.
- So it's a really incredibly
enlightening moment.
Do you know the difference
between equity and equality?
And it's basically
saying to him,
do you know the
difference between
socialism and capitalism,
in essence?
And Bernie fumbles, fumbles,
and then basically
says, "I don't know."
And Bill explains it to him,
and it's like,
well, wait a minute,
you've been the prime
mover of these ideas,
from a economic
perspective at least.
I don't think he realized how
it was gonna become racialized
and sexualized and
everything else.
But it was clear to me that
he just didn't even know
what he was talking about.
- That doesn't surprise me.
I mentioned Bernie
in "An Immigrant's Love
Letter to the West"
because it boggles my mind
how anyone in this country
takes him seriously.
This is a guy who honeymooned
in the Soviet Union,
where he would've had
exactly the same experience
as every other westerner
coming to the Soviet Union.
They would've been taken
to some fake wedding
where fake KGB agents were
having a fake wedding.
And then they would be
taken on some kind of trip.
Every movement
would be controlled.
And these are the
people who came back
from the Soviet Union,
I can't remember if it was,
I don't wanna
slander dead people,
but I can't remember
who it was, somebody,
one of these
darlings of the left
came back from the Soviet
Union in 1938 as people,
millions of my
ancestors, you know,
my countrymen and
women were starving,
and said, "I've
never eaten as well
as I did in the Soviet Union."
These gullible
clowns in the West
who have never
experienced socialism,
have never
experienced communism,
who sell simple but
false ideas to people.
They don't deserve to be
taken seriously. They don't.
And they don't
offer any solutions.
The solutions that they offer
will be counterproductive
and hurt people in this
country and around the world.
It boggles my mind that
people don't understand that.
But they don't.
- When you, I know
you've only been,
wait, how many days in America?
You're in Florida for a day,
but you've been in America
for a couple of days.
- Yeah, we've been in America
about a week and a bit now.
- For about a week. And how
much longer are you here?
- Another week and a bit.
- All right, so you got two
some odd weeks in America.
You're bouncing around to some
different states, I assume.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you sense, or maybe
it's a little premature,
that the federalist
system that we have here,
where Florida can be so
different than California,
is the escape route
of all of this?
That's really been my
saving grace in all of this.
That by picking up,
moving my life, my family,
my businesses, et cetera, that
I have roots now in a place
that my ideas and the things
that I care about can flourish.
And they couldn't flourish.
I didn't have to leave the
country, in other words.
Where it would be trickier
for someone from the UK
or someone from Canada,
you kind of gotta go.
- You were very mild in
the way you describe it.
You can't.
- Yeah.
- It's not tricky.
It's impossible.
During COVID, we, there
was no part of the country
that was better than the
one that I was living in.
And even within
the European Union,
which we're no
longer members of.
- Is that mind blowing to you?
I mean, just knowing UK is
not not unbelievably massive,
but like there's obviously
some geographic variation,
and London is very different
than going out, you know,
even two hours in any direction.
- Yeah.
- That you don't have
that much flexibility?
- Well, it's kind of the way
in most countries actually.
So what is mind blowing to me
is the incredible
situation you've got here.
And I love it.
- Yeah.
- You know, of course America,
like any country has problems.
But I love that part of it.
I love this.
I think this is a
brilliant country.
I think people don't
say that enough.
People don't hear that enough.
If you are growing
up in America,
or anywhere in the West, really,
but particularly in the
United States right now,
you are the luckiest person
in the history of humanity.
And people, and the reason
we are where we are, Dave,
is people have forgotten that.
And it's become an
unfashionable thing to say,
and a dangerous thing to
say for some, you know,
some people feel really
sort of shy about saying it.
And I, that's why as,
as speaking as a first
generation immigrant,
you know, I feel a duty.
- Yeah.
- I feel a genuine duty
to remind people of that.
- Yeah.
Trust me, you spend a
little more time in Florida
with some of the
Cubans who, you know,
fled Castro or their
parents did or whatever,
it's like these people
free, they'll be,
by the time you spend the
24 hours here, you're gonna,
it's gonna be in you even
more, let's put it that way.
- As Francis always
says, you know,
"Communism is a great red pill."
- Yeah. That's probably
the ultimate red pill.
- Yeah.
- What else has been
on your mind lately?
Like what, you know,
I know we could do
the woke thing always,
and the slight
sort of differences
between the old
liberals and whatever,
but what else have you been
sort of thinking about lately?
- Well, every time we come
to America, first of all,
on a personal level, we're like,
"Okay, we gotta come
and come", I mean,
"We gotta move here", you know?
- Do you really feel
that now, you feel that,
do you feel that more
as a father, actually?
- I feel that less as a father.
- Oh, that's interesting.
- That's actually the one
thing that holds me back.
Because, I have to say,
I think I speak for
a lot of parents now,
in this country and elsewhere,
which is like, you give,
you create this miracle of life.
You nurture it,
you look after it,
you give it everything
you possibly can,
and then you send it off to,
and I mean, the
stuff that they're-
- Yeah.
- Like,
so that to me is terrifying
because I think in this country,
you guys are doing worse
on that issue, actually.
The transition in particular
and the sexualization
of children.
You guys are doing worse
here than we are in the UK.
- Do you fear though, that
it's just a matter of time?
I mean, BLM, the idea that
you guys had a BLM in the UK
where your cops in
London don't have guns,
and there was no problem.
I mean, I hate to
tell you, but like,
go back in three months.
- Right.
- You might have a
problem on your hands.
- I think we're
actually making progress
on the trans issue,
believe it or not.
And I think one of
the reasons that is,
is that it's not a
partisan issue actually.
- Really?
So your left there, the Labor
Party is not all about this
the way our Democrats are?
- The Labor Party
mostly, mostly, is.
But most, or as much of
the pushback culturally
and in sort of in our
space and elsewhere,
is not from people on the right,
it's from gender critical women.
Some feminists, some not.
You know, Posie Parker, who we
were one of the first people
to ever interview
in a long format.
- Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That video's on, that
video got taken down
as hate speech on YouTube.
And then because it was
reinstated, thank God,
the Streisand effect, it's
now 1.3 million views,
for a channel that
at the time had,
I don't know, 100,000
subscribers or something.
So it's people like her.
And what that opens
up is the opportunity
for people who are not on the
right, people like JK Rowling,
people like Rosie
Duffield, who's a Labor MP,
to bravely step forward,
and genuinely bravely,
unlike us, you know, these
people get rape threats
and death threats and
all the rest of it,
and join forces with others
and actually tackle that issue.
The Tavistock Clinic,
which was doing a lot
of these transitions.
I mean, some of the stuff
that's come out in the reports,
I mean, people should
look into that,
because it's absolutely
terrifying, that's
been shut down.
Now that doesn't mean we
are not gonna continue
to have issues with it, but,
we are making some progress.
Nicola Sturgeon, the former
first minister of Scotland,
where they, they had the,
did you follow the story?
- I'm not sure.
- A guy who raped two women.
- No, I don't think
I know this one.
- A guy raped two women,
claimed he was a woman,
and wanted to be in
a women's prison.
We, Francis and I-
- There's many
versions of that. Yeah.
- Yeah, we call it prisoner
onset gender dysphoria.
(Dave laughs)
You get to the
courtroom, suddenly,
"Oof, I feel like a woman."
- Yeah.
- But my point is,
that is being aired,
it is being talked about,
it is being discussed on
mainstream television properly.
And we are making progress.
It doesn't mean we don't
have a long way to go.
But I fear that, my
concern with the way
that this issue is being
discussed in this country,
and I say this as an
outsider, what do I know?
But it's just, if enough
people keep saying
the libs are transing the kids,
you're gonna get
to a position where
that makes it difficult
for left-wing people
to step forward and
talk about this as well.
Do you see what I'm saying?
- Mm hm.
- And I think because of that,
we're actually making
better progress
on that particular issue than
you guys are in this country.
So that issue is the main one
that's holding me back
actually about moving here.
But the thing I love
about it is, you know, if-
- Well, I wouldn't
worry about that,
because there'll
be plenty of states
where your kids
will be just fine.
- Well, exactly. Florida.
As long as it stays purple.
- No, we're red as red.
- You're all red now.
- Florida's basically
the reddest state
in the country in some ways.
I mean, DeSantis
won by 20 points.
Super majorities on both sides,
and nobody's coming
for the gays,
nobody's coming for
the black people.
It's just fine here.
- That's reassuring.
- Yeah.
- And so...
(Dave and Konstantin chuckle)
- I feel like I'm sitting on
the board of tourism here.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- No, you like it here.
- You're not black or gay.
- You like it here.
- You can still be okay here.
- I don't think I
can handle, I mean,
how you boys get any work done
on the sea I have no idea.
But, my point is,
apart from my concerns about
what's happening to children,
this country's great.
It's great.
You wanna build a business?
Sure, go for it.
You wanna do this?
Sure, we'll help.
Like that's the attitude.
And that to me is the
most inspiring thing.
And that's, this isn't me,
you know, shitting on Britain,
because I love Britain too.
But my temperament, I
think, is more suited here.
So I see probably in
the next five years
we're gonna end up here.
So that's on a personal level.
In terms of sort of
societally and culturally,
we talked about it already.
We're gonna have to work out
what to do about social media.
- [Dave] Yep.
- And that's a really tough one.
That's a really,
really tough one.
- Let me ask you
one other thing,
which is that I just
finished watching,
I think it's Season
5 of "The Crown".
First off, did you
watch "The Crown."
- No.
- It will be irrelevant.
You'll know enough
about the monarchy
to be able to
answer my question.
I really enjoyed the
show, and what I,
putting aside any of the
specifics of the episodes,
this idea that the
monarchy exists over time,
and that it is
constantly, I mean,
the whole point of the show
is it's the constant battle
between modernization
and conservatism,
and that something
should last beyond
a Labor government or a
Conservative government.
And in some ways I
watch it, and I think,
"Boy, we could use a little
bit of that in America."
Like something separate
from our daily,
you've got to go
Republican this time,
you've gotta go
Democrat this time,
because it separates
the sort of big ideas
from the day-to-day politics.
And I wonder what
you think of that,
if I explained it in a
somewhat sufficient fashion?
- Look, having a thing
that brings people together
is important.
This is what we've lost. Right?
And the monarchy,
you know, we were
in a transition,
as everyone seems to be,
on that issue as well.
You know, the passing of
the Queen was mourned,
I think, to such an
extent, not only because
she was this extraordinary
person, but because,
you know, people see the England
of their youth going away.
And I think for a lot of people
it was that extra
bit meaningful,
because it kind of marked
the passing of the era,
and we, it remains
to be seen whether,
under the current King,
that continuous thing,
that thing goes on.
I think it probably will.
- According to the
show, at least,
which I think is fairly factual.
I mean, he really was
pushing for change all along.
- Right.
- You know, from youth.
So we shall see.
- And if he makes,
and if he makes the mistake
that his younger son made,
which is to start
weighing in on politics,
I don't think there
will be any way
to defend the Monarchy
at that point,
because the Monarchy's purpose
is not to be party
political or partisan.
And once you start
weighing in on these very,
you know, divisive issues,
as a neutral observer who's
supposed to just provide
the backdrop against which
society takes its course,
then they're gonna be
in a lot of trouble.
So I hope he doesn't do that.
- Konstantin, I'm glad you
made it across the pond.
I'm glad that I had
a little something
to do with the adventure
that you're on,
and we will do it again.
- Thank you very much, Dave.
It's great to be on the show.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.